how does it feel to be here on they go
to glove red carpet it's surreal the
fashion on pose compared to the fashion
on the red carpet here well thank God we
released from the 1980s which is nice so
we could be you didn't want to wear any
of your 80s garb
maash to the eighties they're just
living in the fashion of it all you know
I like your little affair
thank you it's off-white so that's the
brand they love it's what the children
are doing apparently so you're in with
the youth / youth the youth though you
got the Diamonds going on there yes well
you learn that when you work with Ryan
Murphy that a disco ball and more
glitter will make everything better like
that aligned right so how does it feel
the success of pose you know that and
how it's going it's just it's such a
revelation and an affirmation for us you
know our our show is so small and we
have such a small but really amazing
audience and the critics love us so
that's always cool and I think that the
next layer of that is that we get to
tell a important story about people who
are never the heroes and so MJ gets to
play a heroine on a series that's on
television and that's really
revolutionary and kind of amazing it'd
be bad if the critics didn't like you
wouldn't it it would be it's nice to be
a critics darling do you have a fan of a
show that is here tonight killing you I
love Sandra Oh I'm so excited to see her
host tonight I won't say this it was
also great to just be in the space where
we're being you know accepted as actors
and actresses in the space
we've never gotten to before so I think
that's the most wonderful thing about
being here at the Golden Globes one of
the biggest biggest biggest war
ceremonies that anyone could ever be out
yeah and women about to get from home
our experience good to be here and get
to shine a light on the many people want
to be like us you know what I mean I
think that's the best part about this
whole experience well congratulations
have a wonderful time tonight have a lot
of fun give this video
[Music]